(intense music)
(roars)
- It's Godzilla.
- Well, friends, it is time to
answer the age-old question:
Who would win a fight between a giant ape
and a building-sized lizard?
We're breaking down everything we know
about "Godzilla vs. Kong"
right now on The Ketchup.
On March 31, "Godzilla vs. Kong"
will hit theaters and
HBO Max simultaneously
and we are here for it.
The fourth film in
Legendary's MonsterVerse,
"GVK," as I'm calling it, is
a sequel to 2014's "Godzilla"
as well as "Godzilla:
King of the Monsters"
and "Kong: Skull Island."
It also marks the first time
these two larger-than-life
leviathans have shared a screen
since 1962's "King Kong vs. Godzilla."
Legendary has armed "Blair
Witch" director Adam Wingard
with a reported $200 million budget,
and after seeing the trailer,
we think he put it to good use.
"Godzilla vs. Kong" looks
like both an epic brawl
that'll have audiences cheering
for the giant lizard and ape
and a nail-biting disaster
film for the humans
unlucky enough to be sitting
ringside to the fight,
which, this time around, includes
Alexander Skarsgard, Rebecca
Hall, Brian Tyree Henry,
and returning cast members
Millie Bobby Brown and Kyle Chandler.
The only question now is who
do you have your money on?
- Kong bows to no one.
- Updating the franchise for
a new generation of superfans,
Legendary's kaiju are now called titans.
The Godzilla legacy,
meanwhile, sheds its original
thesis warning about nuclear
capabilities during war
for a more relevant message
about global warming and eco-terrorism.
See, in this version of Godzilla,
the radiation emitted by the titans
is actually healing the planet
and Godzilla, while not
exactly a pro-humanist,
is definitely working to restore
balance in the ecosystem.
Also, there are aliens, as introduced by
the three-headed space dragon Ghidorah
in "King of the Monsters."
Does that explain the tiny spaceship
next to Kong's inverted
head in the new trailer
or explain where he got his new weapon?
Only time will tell,
but speaking of Kong...
- Is that a monkey?
- We actually don't know that much about
what Kong has been up to since
we last saw him in the 1970s
in the events of "Kong: Skull Island."
I guess he's just hanging out,
making friends with small orphan girls
and chillaxing, if people
still use that word.
But you know, giant gorilla stuff.
We do know that Monarch,
the government agency working
to understand the titans
in "Godzilla: King of the Monsters,"
was already a shadowy government
organization decades prior
and actively searching for Kong.
We also know from the cave painting scene
in the closing credits of the film
that Kong has tangled with kaiju before,
including Mothra, Rodan, King Ghidorah,
and, yes, Godzilla himself.
Most importantly, though,
we can see that Kong
had a bit of a growth spurt
since the last time we saw him,
going from roughly 100 feet tall
to somewhere in the neighborhood
of 300 feet in this film.
Supposedly, that is because Kong
was just an adolescent
the last time we saw him,
and I mean, come on, they
gotta make it a fair fight.
- Let me list all the
ways you're gonna die.
- So, who will win in a fight
between these two mega-predators?
Well, the last time these two met,
in 1962's "King Kong vs. Godzilla,"
it looked like Godzilla
had the upper hand.
I mean, after all, he is
the king of the monsters.
King Kong, on the other hand,
is just a very large gorilla
who gets sleepy if he
eats too many red berries.
I know the feeling.
After Kong floats to the top of Mount Fuji
on a bunch of balloons -
yup, you heard that right -
he is struck by lightning,
develops his own super powers,
and pummels the amphibious
lizard back into the ocean,
only to resurface alone.
So, Kong wins and it's the end. Or is it?
Hint: It is definitely not the end.
So, does that mean we can expect
to see the king of monsters
bow down to the king of Kongs yet again?
It's impossible to guess.
Our guess is actually
that the true villains
are probably not either monster,
since they both have vested interests
in protecting at least some of humanity,
not to mention future
franchise installments.
- [Off Camera] Who bows to who?
(intense music)
- But friends, it is time for
us to kick it over to you now.
What are your theories
around "Godzilla vs. Kong?"
Let us know in the comments section.
Also let us know who you think
is gonna win this epic brawl.
And of course, if you want
more movie and streaming news,
head on over to RottenTomatoes.com.
Also, be sure to check
out our show "Versus"
for an even more in-depth breakdown
of Godzilla and Kong
duking it out on screen.
As always, my name's Naz
Perez for Rotten Tomatoes.
We can't thank you enough
for watching The Ketchup
and I got my money on...
Honestly, I have no idea
who to put my money on.
You tell me.
Bye.
(upbeat music)